les chevalements soir
patrick chauvel donc vous êtes
photographe vous êtes né en 1949 et vos
images ont fait la une des plus grands
magazines du monde
paris-match time magazine newsweek life
et vous avez travaillé aussi pour cinéma
vous est raccourcie par est votre film
rapporteur de guerre qu plurielle a fait
le tour du monde au genou publié un
livre s'appellera porter au singulier de
guerre chez oh éditions mais la nation
[Musique]
la batterie chauvel vous êtes depuis 35
ans sur tous les fronts du monde la
guerre des six jours au moyen-orient au
début ensuite le vietnam le cambodge
verlande l'iran le liban panama
l'afghanistan la tchétchénie blévec
pratiquement tout fait je crois que ya
pas une guerre vous n'étiez pas votre
livre commence à panama city touché vous
êtes de blessés vous dites petites roues
dans les tripes et une côte qui sort
dans le dos et vous dites je vais mourir
et là vous marquez votre groupe sanguin
sur votre front pourquoi commencer votre
livre par cette scène
parce que c'est dans ce genre de
situation on se demande pourquoi on fait
ce métier de dengue et donc c'est un
espèce de moments où on se pose les
questions sur le pourquoi de ce métier
donc j'ai voulu commencer scrive part ça
parce que ça montre que ça se fait c'est
un métier un peu difficile par moments
il ya quand même des impondérables
sérieux et donc voila voila donc vous
êtes touché à panama city on vous ramène
à l'hôtel marriott pour une opération et
au réveil
vous demandez aux infirmiers vous dit
vous avez fait quoi et le mec vous dit
tout va bien on vous a coupé les bowls
en hélico et couper les couilles et là
ça dieu tel pour vous vous imaginez que
c'est un peu embêtant
et en fait c'était les bowe c'est à dire
les intestins c'est embêtant aussi mais
c'est moins embêtant
donc on mange moins mais on peut
toujours faire des petits rapporteurs
guerre après quoi
ces américains qui nous ont tiré dessus
parce que vous ne faisiez pas partie du
du pool de journalistes exactement c'est
ce qui s'appelle freine les failles les
tirs amicaux voilà donc il vaut mieux
pas être leur pote ça c'est à panama en
89 et vous fait ça depuis 1967 donc
après vous reprenez des choses dans
votre livre en ordre chronologique
67 donc depuis la guerre des six jours
un soir vous dînez avec votre père qui
est grand reporter au figaro
ils vont rencontrer gilles caron jkr
enquête une star dans le métier et le
lendemain vous partez pour israël donc
avec un leica prêté par le même gilles
caron et 500 francs à l'époque c'était
beaucoup d'argent ça sent fort mais
énorme c'était un cadeau de votre perdre
est alors en descendant du bateau en
arrivant là bas en israël vous apprenez
que la guerre a éclaté vous avez
vraiment le sens du timing quand même
assez essentiel le sens du timing la
chance ce sont vraiment les deux
mamelles de ce métier ouais alors voilà
vous êtes en israël au moment de la
guerre des six-jours et de retour à
paris vous découvre en fait que 90% des
photos que vous avez fait là bas sont
complètement ratée et donc ce moment-là
vous rentrez au labo de france soir pour
apprendre très bonne école
c'est à l'époque un grand journal
aujourd'hui m6 mais il y avait beaucoup
de photographes y avait 25 photographes
à l'époque ils m'ont un peu pris sous
leurs coups c'est la grande époque de
france soir et peu de hasard êtes vous
mariée à ce moment là avec anne marie
elle a beaucoup souffert ensuite de
votre vie n'ont
souffert je ne sais pas mais c'est vrai
que trois jours après mon mariage est
que cette charmante danseuse elle était
danseuse étoile je suis partie au
mozambique pour 15 jours avec maurice
ronet pour faire un documentaire et je
suis revenu un an ouais donc c'est là
qu'elle était noyée humeur quand je suis
rentré
qu'en même temps le mariage huit ans
mais je suis on s'est vu huit mois alors
69 porté au vietnam
napalm mines antipersonnel vous parlez
dans votre bouquin des mines
antipersonnel c'est absolument bon sans
doute aimé c'est absolument terrible dit
c'est fait pour péter canton relève le
pied 1
s'arrachent les reins les jambes il sera
exposé les couilles et de vendre du mec
qui est derrière ouais alors je m'en
suis aperçu assez vite puisque j'ai
assisté à ça plusieurs fois et
d'ailleurs je suivais un énorme
mariinsky à mambé s'est retourné et m'a
dit tu sais ça ça sert à rien de te
coller à moi parce que moi je me collais
à lui parce que d'abord il était
photogénique et en plus il me protégeait
un peu et en fait je après je les
laissais passer devant quand ce n'était
pas la peine tout quoi il est
extraordinaire marché à un moment dans
les rizières justement on parlait de ses
mines anti personnel pour vous mettez à
banc des siens je pensais à autre chose
et
c'est beau une rizière ce soir
non en fait c'est je pensais en fait je
regardais le décalage horaire et à paris
il était 6 heures du matin kelly banc
dès
6 heures et 6 heures
soit aussi c'est à la même heure un goal
matinale mais bon avec le décalage
horaire et pas twitter non mais c'est
extraordinaire ce gouvernement vous et
essayeront ya une boîte s'appelle la
cigale qui est tenu par un corps
justement et vous remarquez une
vietnamienne de 16 ans qui s'appelle dao
alors vite qu'elle est vierge pieds et
vous décidé de la sortir de là oui dit
aux corses combien pour qu'elles bossent
plus il y trop cher pour toi toute façon
tu finiras par te faire tuer et elle
sera plus de tout ça mais il était assez
pragmatique je viens mais en fait je me
suis pas fait tuer mais elle est devenue
buts en 72 est un peu mal parce que vous
êtes en irlande à ce moment là lire à
mouzon mène sur le lieu d'une exécution
sur le lieu d'une d'une embuscade contre
l'armée anglaise et là on vous emmène
avec les yeux bandés on vous des bandes
les yeux vous photographiez
effectivement la scène et vous vous
sentez mal à vous sentez complice à ce
moment là c'est à dire que la ligne est
très très fine entre la complicité d'un
événement est la non assistance à
personne en danger j'ai vu les soldats
anglais avancée dans la rue et je savais
qu'il y avait une bombe mais mais bon là
vous prenez une balle dans le fémur vous
en irlande un service et c'est fou le
nombre de blessures vous avez une
aubaine oui on n'est pas étanche 1 c'est
un métier un peu difficile pour
l'irlande se vend mal vous dit votre
rédacteur en chef donc vous devenez
paparazzi comme absolument
extraordinaire après tout ça
même si vous connaissez pas bien les
pipoles a pas vraiment bien je vous fait
une centaine de photos d'un mec en
croyant que c'est aux nazis c'est en
fait c'est pas lui jean michel mouillart
en fait c'est un chauffeur qui
ressemblait ont assisté qui attendait
une dame âgée devant l'immeuble où
habitait la callas et j'ai cru que
c'était au nazisme et il m'a laissé
prendre des photos je me suis dit on
assiste plutôt sympa hein j'ai dû faire
des films sur lui il avait l'air un peu
ahuri quand je prenais en photo 1 donc
si jamais ils écoutent cette émission
j'ai cinq mille photos de lui on peut
mieux
une vie à 100 c
est insensé en 75 et en erythrée et là
il ya un rebelle et les trains qui se
prend un intrus dans la tête et alors il
ya c'est terrible à dire mais bon il ya
plus d'eau sa filiale il ya cerveau qui
palpite comme ça au fond d'la et alors
les mets qu'ils écrasent le sujet il lui
met de l'aspirine sur le cerveau qui qui
bat comme ça c'est un anticoagulant et
en même temps donc c'est vraiment la
seule chose qu'il fallait pas faire ils
l'ont tel-aviv en ayant enterré vivant
c'est impossible c'est vrai que c'est
ses pieds m'obsède assez souvent
quelquefois je me gratte faisant tourner
je cherche si j'ai un trou en 77 vous
retourne encore une fois aux vivants et
là vous êtes accusé d'être un espion
israélien
face à wihr quand même un peu de
vinaigre
vous êtes condamnés à rester en taule
pendant 18 ans lui fait une tentative de
suicide puisque jamais m'en sortir vous
mordez des fils électriques
coup de bol n'ya pas de courant ces
israéliens qui avait bombardé une heure
avant donc y avait plus d'électricité
donc d'ailleurs le gardien m'a dit elle
finalement tué décidément israélien oui
puisqu'ils seront pour par 291 vous êtes
à haïti avec les boat people alors là
c'est des gens qui faisaient quand 1000
km cg pas imaginer ça je les ai vus en
lisant votre bouquin 1000 km dans des
barques surchargées qui faisait 6 7 m 2
de long vont le radeau de la méduse quoi
c'est l'été 44 sur le premier bateau je
crie à la coulée évidemment et
sur les 44 ya eu 14 survivants tant que
mais en même temps quand je suis quand
je suis parti sur le bateau je me suis
tu fais une connerie parce que il coule
tous non temps je voyais pas d'autre
moyen de raconter leur histoire parce
qu'en fait tu t'en fous ravir les gens
qui prennent le bateau ok bon ils
prennent le bateau est alors raconte
tout se révèle une fois qu'on est en mer
depuis trois jours et trois nuits et à
son latin est-ce qu'ils ont raconté leur
histoire une question simple pour
supporter tout ça vous colle maintenant
sérieux
des trucs non non mais c'est pas d'or on
peut le dire je n'y a rien de non jeu
complètement bourré ce soir parce que
j'ai peur mais non non non c'est plus
peur ce soir que ça va évidemment
alors le bilan de tout ça me dit je ne
sais pas si mes photos servent à quelque
chose mais ne pas en faire ne sert à
rien voilà c'est clair moi ça se trouve
que ça résume assez bien toute la sphère
derrière et hewitt or en témoigne parce
que comme ça on pourra plus dire on ne
savait pas mais c'est pour qu'on mesure
le parent le plaisir d'une émission
comme ça de de rencontrer des gens comme
vous c'est à dire carrément donné c'est
un vrai plaisir mais il faut savoir que
c'est vraiment formidable et que
ailleurs ça l'est pas et donc pas croire
que c'est dû c'est un acquis justement
c'est ça qui m'intéresse quand vous
partiez comme ça quand vous partez
encore même si maintenant vous avez
laissé tomber la photo pour la caméra
d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant ce que
vous racontez quand vous revenez
apparaît comme ça vous devez nous
trouver ridicule nous avec nos problèmes
d'affaires pas non non absolument pas
parce que c'est vraiment une balance il
faut relativiser les choses toujours
l'histoire d'un caméraman qui était avec
moi en irak quand tu es la guerre irak
iran il ya eu plus d'un million mort on
était dans une tranchée depuis trois
semaines et c'est 14-18 voilà quatre ans
les gaz les morts partout terrain il ya
un radio qui est venu en rampant et qui
elle me dit monsieur dur schmitt votre
femme vous devez appeler votre femme
sauf qu'il a eu une peur bleue c'est
qu'ils arrivent à me joindre dans une
branche et c'est que ces gras tout le
monde est mort c'est pas possible parce
quand on a des enfants on apprend la
quiétude commun donc la quiétude
profonde et donc il a mis cinq joueurs
tournés à bagdad il a appelé chez lui et
sur sa femme déjà elle est vivante et
elle lui dit ta fille veux te parler
donc il va tout le monde est vivant le
poisson rouge est mort
ici donc il a appelé cbs qui travaille
pour cibler ces il a dit je rentre comme
c'était un espèce de fou qui avait peur
de rien qui m'a dit qu'ici attaque balle
dans le ventre une jambe - il dit non le
poisson rouge de ma fille et est mort
mais donc je rentre à paris un multiple
de siviez ce qu'ils avaient des enfants
lui a dit tu rentres il est rentré il
s'est arrêté sur lesquels il a un chien
l'autre poisson s'est enfermé dans la
chambre de sa fille et pendant trois
heures ils ont parlé de la vie et de la
mort parce que pour sa fille c'était une
tragédie et dont il il faut relaté moi
je suis rentré quelques fois de trois
mois de guerre et à l'aéroport ma femme
m'a dit j'ai une semaine de merde j'ai
eu deux pv là ou alors là c'est un choix
quelle conne c'est mal ça donne beaucoup
de ce que veux tu veux continuer à vivre
avec elle tu fais merde c'était le juger
sur merci patrick sur erreur
ces élections pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu